Por supuesto, más del 96% de todas estas
aguas, repartidas a lo largo y ancho de todo
el mundo, se encuentran fuera del territorio
continental europeo que todos identificamos
como la France.
¿No os parece curioso?¿Sorprendente?
Claro que la pregunta que todos podemos hacernos
es, ¿de donde procede semejante dominio marítimo?
Pues bien, creo que no es ningún secreto
que Francia tiene un enorme e intenso pasado
colonial.
Un pasado gracias al cual aún hoy conserva
territorios repartidos por todo el globo el
terraqueo.
(América, África, la Antártida, Oceanía…
Salvo en Asia, los franceses tienen territorios
en todos los continentes del planeta.
Y como cada territorio costero tiene derecho
a unas 200 millas mar adentro de zona económica
exclusiva el resultado es el que acabamos
de ver.
Estos territorios de ultramar son por así
decirlo enclaves estratégicos que le otorgan
a la república francesa una gran proyección
internacional.)
No olvidemos que, además del tema de las
zonas económicas exclusivas, estos territorios
de ultramar también son estratégicos por
muchas otras cuestiones.
Digamos que estos lugares le permiten a Francia
extender su actividad militar por todo el
mundo y también refuerzan su influencia geopolítica.
Por ejemplo hacen que Francia sea la única
potencia europea que posee territorios en
el indopacífico.
Son, por así decirlo, la clave de que Francia
sea el tercer país con mayor huella militar
en el mundo tras Estados Unidos y Rusia.
Otro ejemplo lo tenemos en Kouru (PRON: Kúggu),
en la Guayana Francesa, donde se encuentra
el puerto espacial de la ESA, la NASA europea,
y que es de dónde se lanzan todos los cohetes
espaciales de la agencia europea.
Claro que llegados a este punto hay unas cuantas
preguntas que podemos hacernos:
¿Hasta qué punto estos territorios forman
parte de Francia?
¿Tienen un nivel de vida similar?
¿Están contentos con seguir formando parte
de la república francesa?
¿Cómo les trata París?
Queridos amigos, amigas, en este vídeo intentaremos
conocer un poquito mejor la cara más desconocida
de Francia, y para ello echaremos un vistazo
a cuatro de sus territorios de ultramar más
importantes.
Esto es lo que resta del antiguo imperio francés.
Atentos.
1(LIBERTÉ, ¿ÉGALITÉ?, FRATERNITÉ)
Si alguno pensaba que el lema oficial de la
República Francesa se cumple a rajatabla…
siento deciros que está bastante equivocado.
Al menos en lo que tiene que ver con la “égalité”,
la “igualdad” si reparamos en los casi
3 millones franceses que no viven en la Francia
metropolitana de la vieja Europa, sino a miles
de kilómetros de distancia.
Unos franceses que, en bastantes casos, están
empezando a enfadarse con su situación.
Razones no les faltan.
[Pero antes de entrar en eso, un pequeño
paréntesis, ¿Habéis oído hablar de nuestro
boletín semanal exclusivo para patronos?
¿Habéis oído hablar de los productos exclusivos
de VisualPolitik que no están a la venta
en ningún otro sitio?
¿Queréis recibir vídeos exclusivos periódicamente?
Pues si os gusta lo que hacemos y queréis
ayudarnos a seguir creciendo y mejorando,
podéis encontrar todo esto y más en la comunidad
de Patreon de VisualPolitik.
Os dejamos el enlace en la descripción]
Pero dicho esto sigamos con el tema que hoy
nos ocupa.
Empecemos mirando el bolsillo.
Si algo caracteriza a los territorios franceses
de ultramar son sus pobres condiciones socioeconómicas.
(En la Francia de ultramar las tasas de pobreza
son mucho más elevadas que en la metrópoli.
Por ejemplo, si en la Francia europea el porcentaje
de la población por debajo del umbral de
la pobreza ronda el 15%, en el resto de territorios
de la república la cifra se dispara.
Por ejemplo, en Mayotte la tasa de pobreza
se sitúa en el 77,3%, en la Guayana Francesa
en el 52,9, en Guadalupe en el 34,5 y en Martinica
en el 28,6%.)
Pero, como esto de las tasas de pobreza es
algo bastante relativo, ¿Qué ocurre si nos
fijamos, por ejemplo, en el PIB per cápita?
¿También hay diferencias?
Pues…
Lo cierto es que sí.
El territorio francés de ultramar más rico,
Reunión, tiene un PIB per cápita de unos
25.000 dólares, mientras que el departamento
más pobre de la Francia metropolitana, Centre-Val
de Loire, tiene un PIB per cápita de unos
31.500 dólares.
Es decir, un 26% más.
Para colmo estos lugares son muy dependientes
de los euros que emanan del presupuesto público
de Francia y, más recientemente, también
de los fondos de la Unión Europea.
Una situación que tiene mucho que ver con
la falta de libertades económicas y descentralización
que sufren estos territorios.
A diferencia de Londres, que históricamente
ha dado plena libertad a sus territorios de
ultramar, París ha transitado un camino muy
diferente.
No tiene sentido que el grueso de las leyes,
incluida la legislación tributaria, las normas
comerciales y gran parte de las regulaciones
de Francia se apliquen en lugares tan remotos,
tan diferentes y en algunos casos tan pobres
como los territorios de ultramar.
Sí, es cierto que en el año 2000 se llevó
a cabo una pequeña descentralización que
hace que estos territorios cuenten con algunas
normas y leyes diferentes a la metrópoli
y también cuentan con algún incentivo fiscal.
Pero ni por asomo ha sido suficiente.
Sí, en algunos casos, como el de Nueva Caledonia,
cuentan, incluso, con sus propias cámaras
legislativas, pero salvo excepciones al final
todo termina pasando por París.
Esto es algo que viene de lejos.
De hecho estos territorios también tienen
un grado de integración comercial muy bajo
con cualquier cosa que no sea Francia.
Una situación heredada del principio de exclusividad
que prohibía a las colonias francesas cualquier
relación comercial con países extranjeros,
dejando con ello a la metrópolis un monopolio
comercial con sus colonias.
En su atraso económico también está relacionado
con su pasado esclavista, el cual dio lugar
a una enorme hiperespecialización de la economía
de estos lugares en actividades de bajo valor
añadido como la producción de caña, plátano,
algodón o cacao.
Pero la económica no es la única brecha
entre franceses que nos vamos a encontrar.
Hablamos de importantes diferencias políticas
y sociales que, en algunos casos, incluso
están amenazando la propia soberanía de
Francia.
Atentos.
2(NUEVA CALEDONIA: ¿INDEPENDENCIA A LA VISTA?)
Nueva Caledonia es un territorio francés
situado en un archipiélago de decenas de
islas en esa maravilla conocida como Pacífico
Sur.
Junto con la Polinesia Francesa, son los dos
territorios con más autonomía y los dos
únicos catalogados por la ONU como territorios
no autónomos que, de alguna u otra forma,
están pendientes de ser descolonizados.
Es decir, que están pendientes de decidir
en un referéndum si optan por la independencia
o por mantenerse dentro de Francia con un
cierto grado de autogobierno.
Pues bien, el caso de Nueva Caledonia, es
especial.
En 1998 se cerró el Acuerdo de Numea por
el que se transferirían ciertas competencias
del gobierno francés a este departamento.
Y también se acordó la celebración de varios
referéndums de independencia que tuvieron
lugar en 2018, 2020 y 2021.
Referéndums en los que, por cierto, la abrumadora
mayoría votó a favor de seguir perteneciendo
a Francia.
Ahora bien, ¿Por qué decimos que el caso
de Nueva Caledonia es especial?
Pues veréis, la realidad es que en este tema
de los referéndums hay mucha tela que cortar.
Una buena parte de los neocaledonios que están
a favor de independizarse de Francia no participaron
en esos referéndums para intentar boicotearlos
y deslegitimarlos mediante quórums muy bajos.
(El movimiento pro-independencia de Nueva
Caledonia rechaza la legitimidad del voto
al “No” - Reuters)
De esta forma, en el último referéndum celebrado
en 2021, el no a la independencia ganó con
el 96,5% de los votos.
Eso sí la participación fue de apenas el
44%.
Es decir, que bien podríamos pensar que aproximadamente
la otra mitad de la población no está a
favor de seguir formando parte de Francia.
La explicación de semejante descontento seguramente
tenga mucho que ver con la sensación de ser
ciudadanos de tercera y no tener la capacidad
de cambiar nada.
3(EL PEDAZO MÁS POBRE DE FRANCIA)
Nueva Caledonia, no es el único territorio
de ultramar francés que se siente, en cierto
modo, marginado por la metrópoli.
También tenemos el caso de Mayotte, una isla
francesa nueve veces más pequeña que Mallorca
enclavada entre Madagascar y Mozambique que
es, con diferencia, el territorio francés
más pobre.
Mayotte fue la única de las cuatro islas
Comoras que en 1974 votaron a favor de seguir
perteneciendo a Francia, mientras que las
otras tres formaron un Estado independiente,
al que por cierto, tampoco le ha ido nada
bien.
(A pesar de formar parte de Francia y de contar
con espectaculares paisajes, aguas cristalinas
de color turquesa y frondosas y verdes montañas
que hacen las delicias de los turistas, en
Mayotte una buena parte de la población vive
poco menos que en infraviviendas, y una gran
cantidad de calles por no tener no tienen
ni asfalto.
Pese a ello, su situación es considerablemente
mejor que las islas Comoras, desde donde procede
una gran cantidad de inmigrantes.
La idea de ser parte de Francia y de la Unión
Europea ha atraído a muchos comorenses a
Mayotte, hasta el punto de que, a día de
hoy, solo el 45% de los mayotenses han nacido
en la isla, y el 70% de los niños nacidos
en Mamoudzou, su capital, lo hicieron de madres
extranjeras.)
A los problemas económicos y la falta de
oportunidades se le suman problemas sociales
de todo tipo, entre los que se incluye también
una creciente inseguridad.
Lo que explica noticias como esta:
(Disturbios en Mayotte: los residentes de
la isla francesa acorralan a los 'extranjeros'
- BBC
Un grupo de residentes de la isla francesa
de Mayotte, en el Océano Índico, ha estado
reuniendo a presuntos inmigrantes ilegales
y llevándolos ante la policía local.)
Por supuesto, todo esto políticamente se
traduce en titulares como este:
N3(Marine Le Pen a la cabeza en Mayotte, gran
avance para Jean-Luc Mélenchon y voto de
castigo contra Emmanuel Macron - Franceinfo)
Sí, puede que os sorprenda, pero en los territorios
africanos de África gana Le pen.
¿Y qué hace el Elíseo para intentar cambiar
las cosas?
Pues básicamente nada excepto la vieja fórmula
de soltar más y más dinero.
Lo que lejos de alimentar el desarrollo ha
hecho que esta isla - al igual que lo que
ocurre con el resto de territorios - tengan
una dependencia brutal de la metrópoli, lo
que ha hecho de ellos lugares rentistas de
París.
Sin las subvenciones de Francia en muchos
de estos territorios no podrían siquiera
satisfacer sus necesidades más básicas.
Es una cuestión de modelo.
Si por un lado tienes que cumplir con toda
la farragosa burocracia y la interminables
regulaciones de Francia que hacen difícil
tener empresas competitivas y por otrola metrópoli
te riega de dinero para financiar todo tipo
de servicios sociales, ¿qué haces?
Pues es una cuestión de incentivos…
Te especializas en intentar que llegue más
y más dinero.
Te vuelves rentista del presupuesto público.
Pero, visto el caso
de Mayotte.
Sigamos.
4(LA FRANCIA CARIBEÑA)
Desde Mayotte podemos cruzar medio mundo y
volver a aterrizar en Francia.
Concretamente en las islas caribeñas de Guadalupe,
Martinica, San Bartolomé y San Martín.
De todas ellas, los guadalupeños y martiniqueños
son quizás los menos satisfechos con su estatus.
Una buena parte de su población se siente
discriminada por París.
¿Un ejemplo?
Pues tenemos el caso de un pesticida.
Sí, un pesticida que causó todo un revuelo
en Guadalupe y Martinica hace ya algunos años.
(La clordecona es un pesticida que era ampliamente
utilizado en plantaciones de plátano.
El problema con él, es que era tóxico.
Hasta aquí, digamos, todo normal, cosas por
el estilo han pasado en todas partes.
Lo que no es tan normal es que Francia aprobase
su uso en Guadalupe dos años después de
que, en 1979, la OMS lo declarase potencialmente
cancerígeno.
Tampoco parece tan normal que, un tiempo después,
se descubriera que una investigación parlamentaria
en la vecina isla de Martinica, donde también
se empleó este pesticida, determinó que
Francia estaba al tanto de la toxicidad de
este quimismo desde 1969 y aún así no evitó
que estos territorios de ultramar lo emplearan
intensamente.)
Evidentemente este tipo de cosas no contribuyen
mucho a crear una sensación de pertenencia
a la nación francesa.
En este paso la percepción más extendida
en estos lugares es que sus vidas, por decirlo
de alguna forma, les importa un rábano a
los burócratas de París.
Claro que esta percepción viene de lejos.
Algo muy enraizado en la cosmovisión local
es su pasado esclavista y lo que ocurrió
con su abolición.
Cuándo se abolió la esclavitud, Francia
compensó a los propietarios de esclavos por
la pérdida sufrida.
Esto es algo que quedó grabado a fuego en
la identidad local.
Y así podríamos seguir con muchos más ejemplos.
Los problemas económicos, sociales y de pertenencia
son comunes en la mayor parte de estos territorios.
Y la explicación es que la metrópoli nunca
les ha dado alas.
Si estos territorios hubieran tenido más
libertad y más competencias algunos de ellos
podrían haber explotado la seguridad jurídica
y política que aporta formar parte de un
país como Francia para convertirse en enclaves
financieros, turísticos o, incluso, industriales.
Qué es, por ejemplo, lo que sí ha ocurrido
con muchos territorios británicos de ultramar:
desde Gibraltar, hasta las Bermudas pasando
en su día por la mismísima Hong Kong.
Asimimsmo, la incapacidad de París para enfrentarse
a los problemas sociales que hay en estos
lugares como la violancia, la inseguridad
o la inmigración ilegal, hace ya tiempo que
debería haber convencido al gobierno francés
de que la descentralizacion era en estos casos
la mejor y quizás única solución posible.
No tiene sentido que estos lugares situados
a miles y miles y miles de kilómetros de
Francia dependan de París prácticamente
para todos.
Y tampoco tiene sentido que los franceses
hayan sustituido la libertad económica por
subsidios y ayudas.
Pero, queridos amigos, amigas, ¡hablamos
de Francia!
Quizás el país más centralista e intervencionista
de toda la vieja Europa.
La pregunta ahora es para ti: ¿Qué crees
que debería hacer Francia con estos territorios?
Dejanos tus respuestas por aquí abajo en
los comentarios y si este vídeo te ha resultado
interesante no olvides darle al botón de
like.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.